[Music]
do you have any car repairs you've been
putting off because of the pandemic
well repair smith has you covered and
you don't even have to leave home
[Music]
it's really really is convenience and
especially during these pandemic times
it's
really helpful for our customers nobody
likes to go into a dealership and
sit around an enclosed environment and
wait for their vehicle
here you're speaking directly to your
technician and you can ask about certain
things on your vehicle
get correct information the first time
if you need any automotive services like
repair or maintenance you can go on our
website repairsmith.com
uh tell us what you need and get an
upfront transparent pr
quote we provide fair pricing there's no
extra
you know premium for us coming to you
and then you can book an appointment
online
uh and it's generally one to three day
uh wait time for the
first available appointment so we get
there pretty quickly and
our technician will arrive in a fully uh
built out van that has all the
power and tools and equipment necessary
for 90 plus percent of modern car repair
in your driveway
for a no contact experience i would
highly recommend it
i i don't think there's any safer way of
getting your car maintained
if you have concerns about leaving the
house and being around other people or
waiting and being in a waiting room and
being exposed to covid you don't have to
worry about that in this scenario
we've been operating for a year now and
you know we get five-star reviews every
day because people really
like the service and a lot of our
customers say you know why hasn't
somebody done this before wise and
always been like this
and it did take a big investment to get
it to work with these
with the vans and the training and the
technology but but
now that we've got it operating smoothly
it's a really
a unique experience i'm just all-around
ase certified master mechanic
all of our technicians are ac certified
and
they generally have 10 plus years of
experience working on multi-brand
vehicles so
um you know we try to hire the best
technicians who can go out and
work independently and
you know the quality of the repair
service we're providing is critical
because as you said our main investor is
mercedes and
uh you know we're not going to put out a
low quality experience or low quality of
service so
we really have the best technicians i
was actually working
at a local dealership um the
clientele was actually dwindling down
because nobody wanted to come out
um they they had hunted me through a
website and it seemed like a better
opportunity than where i was at so
i signed on and couldn't be happier i
mean we probably hired close to 100
people since the pandemic started
and we're actively hiring today so if
any experienced technicians
in the las vegas area are looking for a
new exciting career opportunity
certainly they can go onto our website
and click on the jobs link and apply
online
i would say we have the best repair
experience
in the country right now in transparent
pricing
so you know where you're gonna pay up
front rather than kind of getting
trapped uh
in a in a one one spot and we come to
you right so what's better than that
when everyone's spending all this time
at home these days um you know i get my
groceries delivered i get other things
delivered so why not my car repair
call repair smith at 877-907-6484
or visit repairsmith.com they have a
great special offer for local car
earners use the code las vegas at
checkout
for 25 off your first repair